in Dayton this morning we have a story
of one man's heroism in the middle of
that city's deadly attack terrifying
video shows Cameron Crowder jumping on
top of his girlfriend protecting her
from the gunman who was shooting just a
few yards away from them Dean Reynolds
is in Dayton Dean it sounds like this
couple was extremely lucky incredibly
lucky they both made it out unscathed
thanks to Crowder's selfless act and his
girlfriend says that she's convinced
were it not for him they would not be
around to tell this tale are you still
playing these moments over in your head
I mean yet constantly this is the moment
Cameron Crowder and his girlfriend
Brittany Dungey will never forget just
[Music]
15 feet away
Dayton shooter Connor Betts began his
violent rampage that killed nine people
I saw people get hit like I literally
saw him fall and people get hit I was
certain that you know I was gonna be you
know next in line really is at some
point as bullets flew past them the new
father jumped on top of his girlfriend
shielding her from the gunfire I can't
imagine what your heart must have been
beating like yeah it was a pretty
nervous
I'm not felt for sure that it was only
my last day really being alive you
thought that by falling to the ground
you'd present less of a target was
really about me getting her out of the
way and you know make sure she was safe
I got the world coming to you was just a
trail of bodies laying there I seen pop
up walking like I got hit late on the
side walking in the middle of the street
the horror was over 30 seconds later
when police shot and killed the shooter
why do you think you were spared I mean
it's the grace of God really I mean I
was just one of the lucky ones
authorities continue to look for a
motive in this shooting the police chief
told us that every woman they've
interviewed so far has been cooperating
Anthony